Rhomeyn Johnson, Actor: And also what that does is
psychologically… these are secrets
here I'm giving everybody by the way.
Film Courage: How is commercial work
different from other types of acting?
Rhomeyn: It depends it depends on what type of
commercial it is. You have commercials where you
have it'll be a serious commercial dealing with
say drugs or whatever or maybe teen pregnancy
or whatever and they might get a commercial to
look more like a TV or a film okay then you have
commercial auditions where is really Broad and
high comedy like sitcom I've done all different
types of commercials over the years where
they might have me do a sitcom type commercial
or they might have me do something like a more
dramatic commercial where you have to really act
or be able to pull that off but the more versatile
you are of course the more money you make and the
more opportunities you get what usually happens
in a commercial audition well let me say this
since on a pandemic things have pretty much
changed as far as the auditioning process
you do more self-tape type auditions now people
like me that have been doing it for a long time
prefer to be in the actual agency with the casting
people as and possibly the clients because see
I have a theater background so I still like to
perform and be in front of those folk but when you
self-tape you pretty much they give you the specs
of what they want and you pretty much have to try
to interpret what they want from the specs so you
really don't know necessarily what they want now
if you're fortunate to get a call back and it's
still self or like on Zoom or something then you
know you you're interacting with them so you get
a little more feedback or you actually get a lot
of feedback as far as what they want but I tend to
I tend to book more when I go into the agency more
because it's just part of being like on stage for
me and a lot of actors a lot of actors prefer to
do self tapes because they don't feel comfortable
being in the room I do because I'm a ham
and you think that that maybe you would book
more because they pick up on all the little
improv nuances and then when I come in
the room and I and and I tell people
when they when they go for a commercial audition
in person I tell people I said how you come in the
room and whatnot those first couple of 10 20 30
seconds when you walk in a lot of times they need
to turn that determines whether you might get
the job or whether they might like you or not
what is it what do you think it is it's just like
eye contact or just seeing your body language all
of that and I've been in situations where I've
walked in the room and the people hating me
and you pick you could pick up on stuff and I'm
like okay they don't like me for whatever reason
it could be any reason I was in a situation
before where a guy was saying that he booked a job
because the the the woman from the ad agency had
a boyfriend that looked like him in high school
and then I've been in situations where I've
been in the room where I thought they didn't
like me where I'm just like oh boy I'm not getting
anything from them as far as any feedback or any
warmth and I leave there and on the way home
or whatever I'm driving and my agent will say
they want to put you on a veil I'm like
avail for what? For where you just left.
And then an hour or two later they'll call my
agent and say you booked it I'm like okay and
then when you get on the shoot those same people
that were like come up to you oh we're so glad to
have you here I'm like oh yeah okay then on the
other hand I've been in a room where I've had to
people just like gushing on me oh keep going
that's fantastic nothing so it's hard to say
it's it's just so crazy about how the business is
and and and you just got to just play it by ear
you got to play it by ear but commercials
now commercials now are are pretty much most
of them are now real people type commercials
and they don't do more they don't do as many
serious dramatic commercials unless the subject
calls for it but if you notice from TV everything
is usually kind of funny and kind of and whatnot
because especially over the last couple of years
we've we've we've needed to have people laugh and
be entertained and feel better about themselves
and about the world yes mainly just for themselves
yeah mainly the world we all feel good about
ourselves I feel good about me what are some
do's and don'ts of commercial auditions even
even when you're in the car checking your hair
or whatever checking your teeth what are some
things that you just know don't do this and
make sure to do this okay well at an audition
when you come in the room don't
don't try to befriend people or to
especially on a callback situation now when you go
in for the first audition usually in person you're
in there with a casting person or the director
casting director or assistant and I know everybody
so we'll talk about hey did you see the game or
blah blah blah blah and whatever and then they say
okay you're ready we tape it they don't leave out
because I know the people coming to the Callback
unless I know the director and I know
quite a few of them I still don't
glad hand and hey how you doing buddy I don't
know I don't do that I said hey hey how are you
and the directors usually when they know
me say hey good to see you man and what now
I say well thank you I'm a little more
humble like that and then I try not to
I try not to play to the crowd I try
to really get focused on the director
because the director is the person that is going
to give you whatever direction and feedback you
need and I've done it of course but sometimes
you you might want to play to the people in the
room because they might be laughing and whatnot
you know you got an audience so that's not you
shouldn't do that you should just mainly stay with
the director and a lot of times actors are afraid
to ask questions because most actors are afraid to
either come off like they don't know anything or
like oh I'm I'm imposing on them no when you're
in that room that's your audition and like when
a director says something to me if I don't
understand what they're saying I'll say excuse
me I didn't understand could you say it again you
want me to do such and such and this and that and
they'll say what they want and also what that does
is it's psychologically these are secrets here
I'm giving everybody by the way psychologically
what it does is it makes you have a relationship
with that director because you you you're going
beyond what the script of the commercial is he's
giving you specific instructions of body one
you said what he wants you're like oh yeah okay
and then if you're able to execute it at that
point then that's a plus in in your favor so
and another thing don't please don't linger after
your audition once you finish your audition don't
stay in there and they say well hey I'm glad you
had me here and no no once you're finished say
thank you leave because sometimes see you could
talk your way into a job and you can talk your
way out of it and I've done that before I've
done it because you're human sometimes you
do that and when I've left I said why were you
talking so much in there I say that to myself
then some of them I've gotten in some of them I
haven't but you got to know when the you got to
know when to leave you got to know when to give
yourself that hook you can get out of there you
got to know and when you're on the shoot as
a matter of fact when you're on the shoot
always and I'd say this to young inexperienced
or just basically inexperienced actors
always say thank you to your
clients when you're done
no matter what they're doing where they could
be talking to the director or talking to whoever
once you're done shooting and they say okay
that's a wrap and they say thank you whatever
always go to your clients and say thank you you
could interrupt them no matter what they're doing
is protocol and they will stop talking about
whatever and oh and shake hands say thank you
so much hey it was a pleasure I really enjoyed
this and thank you get it out of there leave
of course you always have to say thank you to
your director and you have to say thank you to
your camera operator and all of the crew but see
I've been doing this so long I know most of these
people like yesterday I did a I did the job for
some people the director and his company I worked
for a few months ago so everybody knew me and I
know I've known those guys a few of them for years
so I'll say hey good to see you how's it how's
your daughter how's your kids doing whatever and
like that and then one thing I do like I didn't
shoot my scene until the end of the day yesterday
so when they broke for lunch they say Okay
actors and whatnot get served first I hadn't
shot anything so the crew is supposed to wait I
said oh no when I got I stood there they said oh
go ahead I said no no you go ahead I haven't done
anything yet and the crew is like wow I said no no
I insist you go ahead and I was one of the last
ones to eat because I hadn't done anything I've
been sitting around all day they like that the the
the directors and the crew people they like that
because you let them know that you are not better
than them you are part of them see we're a team
see but now if I'm working the reason they want us
to go first is because we have to get ready they
have to remake us up or change outfits or whatever
so you go first okay it's understandable but in my
situation I was sitting around like this oh no you
go and they they really appreciate that they might
not say it to you but it's little things like
that when you get on a set with that they remember
now what about when you're sitting in the the
waiting room let's suppose it is an in-person
audition and there's other actors there are you
talking to them are you telling them about a
commercial you just booked what's protocol
it depends it depends on it depends on the
the people you're talking to or I tend
to I tend to not talk too much about it
it's like we were talking about Facebook earlier I
don't really talk much about what I do on Facebook
about the jobs I book I talk about other things
like sports they know about myself and I talk a
little political stuff and people say you don't
talk about anything you do I said no I don't do
that for some reason but I've never been the type
of person that has done that because it's like
yeah I come from I come from a sports background
where it's like I was always taught if you score
a touchdown you don't have to do the dance and
everything you have to act like you already do
that and it's something that you already always
do and you're familiar doing so I tend to like
just kind of flip the ball I didn't flip it much
when I played but I tend to just hand the ball off
and go back to the side I'm kind of like that
as far as the business when something about me
is posted on Facebook as far as work I'm not the
one that put it on there I have friends that say
you need to put that on me I'm like well I'm not
going to do that mainly because I don't know how
and second of all I just don't do that so I tend
to kind of lay back on that well what if you give
an audition and it's not the audition you wanted
to give maybe the performance you wanted to give
maybe you didn't like the direction and you felt
it didn't showcase your talents well that happens
nothing what if you can't redo it then you got
come on you got days where you're gonna be on
and you have days where you're gonna be off
and if you have a track record as far as being
a reliable competent actor casting people know
from from having worked with you or know from
your ex from the experience of seeing your work
or knowing you they know when you're on because
you had those days like anything on any job
some days you don't feel like going to work
and you have to go and then you figure out a way
not to do anything like I used to do in Corporate
America which I got out of there quickly but you
you you have days where you you on in days when
you're off and then there's points where you say
okay unless I can redo the audition then you have
to just deal with it but you want to try to be
you want to try to be grounded in whatever you do
and that's basically from knowing your your
Technique and also from practice and study
and I always always tell people that it doesn't
matter how long or how how long you've been in
the business or how good you think you are you
always have to practice and you always need to
workshop and take classes and whatnot because
there's always something new and you don't know
everything you might think you do but sometimes
you have off days and sometimes you have to just
accept that okay I didn't do it that day see where
a lot of people have problems in this business
is when they get themselves worked up over the
fact that they didn't do exactly what they wanted
and They Carried into another audition or they
carry it into somewhere else and they don't treat
their dog right or what what is significant other
because of that and that's really ridiculous and
when I first got into business I my my first
teacher who was like my mentor at that point
I went to an audition and I didn't do what
I wanted and I left out and I was almost in
tears and I was and I called him up and
I said it didn't go well he says okay
why are you why are you upset like this he says
because it didn't he says do you honestly think
you're gonna do every audition it's gonna be great
then he told me he says no matter what you do
99 of them you're not going to get anyway and
I said huh he says most of the stuff you're
not going to get so why trip out and worry
about it just go in do the best you can at
that point and at that time and let it go now of
course it's nobody lets it go but over the years
what I've done is I've been able to let it go
a lot sooner see so you can't worry about stuff
like that you just have to go ahead on and do
your best and just roll the dice and let it go
do a lot of factors have negative views
about doing commercial work now no
back then you couldn't get a star to even think
about doing a commercial that was an insult
and even when stars do commercials they
will like go over to Japan and place it
or Europe where they got paid millions of
dollars like Paul Newman did that he Paul
Newman's fantastic actor he did a lot of
commercials in Asian in Japan and Europe
and the star big stars will do that now they
get most they get most of the commercials now
and they get paid major dollars the rest of us
they've started to cut our money you know it's
it's kind of gone down for the regular working
actor as far as the amounts of money are these
buyouts by the way I'm not sure exactly how it
is for the stars they might buy them out I'm not
really sure I'm pretty sure they do because the
money is so huge that it would it would offset any
kind of session fee or a use fee or something like
for us you got a session fee and then a use fee so
I don't know I think they might be a kind of a bio
with the Stars because but it's so far over scale
that they can do that and is it different for
internet versus TV versus radio oh yeah well
internet now now you get like a flat rate for
the internet whereas before they would pay you
a certain amount every 13 weeks now it's a
little different and then the like a lot of
people say oh you got paid for every time it runs
that's not the case too much anymore see that was
considered network but the problem with network
now is most people don't watch network television
most people are streaming so now we're
getting screwed on those streaming contracts
like Netflix and Hulu and all those when they show
commercials they give you a flat rate and that's
it if an actor doesn't have an agent can they
still find commercial auditions they can because a
lot of the like like backstage and casting network
and some of those sites they they have auditions
open call for auditions but usually it's it's
like going through agents and casting directors
who deal with agents so it's kind of tight on
that but it's there there are opportunities
what's your final advice to actors who want
to do commercial work any any parting words
well I'll say that
it beats having a regular job because you then
can focus on other things if you're able to
get get jobs and work I haven't I haven't had a
regular job in many years imparting I would say
commercial work is is really almost like the bread
and butter now for for most actors because the
theatrical and TV work is much less than it was
for non-stars and whatnot because as we know in
the theatrical business in films and and whatnot
they tend to skew younger so a lot of the older
actors that were like doing a lot of films
and whatnot they have moved back to TV and
also into commercials because see like I said
commercials no longer have that stigma of being
low rent and beneath somebody because it's so
lucrative if you notice on TV you see more stars
doing commercials athletes and whatnot they're
getting all all of the work and regular folk are
not getting this much work now because everything
is is moving towards that you got like uh Jennifer
Aniston doing cosmetic commercials I just saw J-Lo
last night doing a a commercial at a health club
where she was talking about something and it was
for some product and these are these are A-list
Mega stars and they're doing commercials because
it's easy work for them as far as not as much time
the work is not easy as as easy as people think
but it's it's easier as far as on your schedule
and on and on on your time as opposed to
like say Demi Moore might get a million
dollars for a commercial and she might make a
million dollars say doing a film but she's on
set for like what two weeks or three weeks as
opposed to doing a commercial for eight hours
and most stars don't even stay that long they
leave they're like oh I have to go and then
oh okay because everybody defers to them
and a lot of the advertising people want
to become our tours and become film people
so they tend to want to say hey look can you
check my script out in the stars say oh sure
give it here they don't do anything with it.